it's been a while changing Jersey the
Real Housewives of New Jersey is back
July 10th the first time the show has
aired in over a year and viewers will
see Teresa Giudice is returned from
prison I was back this phone for the
past eleven and a half month
e t--'s Brad Bessie sat down with Andy
Cohen to get all the Schism the first
episode is Teresa's return from prison
and it is I've seen it three or four
times and I wept every time it is the
realest most raw moment that I've seen
when you see these four girls jump in
her arms it's like nothing that I've
seen and and what you'll see as the show
unravels or unfurls this season is you
you do see a different Teresa and you
see how this year away really changed
her and it's very interesting and it's
interesting to see how the the terrain
lays out between she and her
sister-in-law who have never gotten
along you look at the ruins Traci your
soul and she and her ex best friend of
12 years Jacqueline those are the two
relationships to watch and you'll be
surprised by how they turn out